be here now yes such a weird statement
like because
every time i would think of like being
here now
i couldn't feel it for me it's gotta i
gotta be able to integrate it i gotta be
able to
feel it if i can't feel it there's
something wrong with it i gotta
keep digging so i was thinking about
that statement and i was thinking
you know i don't know what here is what
the hell is here
great question you know what is right
now
every now and a moment yeah here now
like in every now moment
and every parallel universe every
possible outcome that could or couldn't
happen that did or didn't come
like right yes what is here so i try i
tried to modify the statement so it
would feel
that i could integrate it and the only
thing i could come up with
and that might sound really weird
because it's the contrary
it was be everywhere at all times yeah
and when i was like
be everywhere and then i could settle
into that
oh yeah i can be everywhere and i can be
at all times
i believe that each and every one of us
has the power within ourselves
to create the life that we really want
and i want to help give you the tools to
make that happen
i'm danica patrick and i'm pretty
intense
for the second phase of my interview
with nasim haramin
a brilliant scientist now we go into
the the real nuts and bolts and the
science of
um reality and what we are as
human beings truly just what we are made
of
as well as reality as we perceive it
and and how we relate to it and then how
we can use it to
better our lives i mean isn't that the
point i think i feel like for me at the
end of the day it ends up being about
why am i going into all of this
information and it ends up being because
i want to be happier and more joyful and
more per
more manifest more of uh the things that
make me happy
and that make life exciting and
interesting
so we get into the nature of reality
please enjoy this fascinating episode
someone was explaining dimensions to me
because dimensions kind of get me a
little bit confused
and in her explanation i was like wow so
we just
end up becoming everything we are every
potentiality
that did and didn't exist which means
you have to become everything so maybe
you could
can you break down dimensions right
in a way that someone like me is going
to understand i
i um you know i have an issue with the
word dimensions because
um it's thought of in many different
ways it's not defined so well
because the spiritual person that's
using the word dimension
is thinking of a whole other world okay
um
the physicist that's you using the word
dimension is thinking of another
cartesian plane or a vector
you know in space and those are two
different things
so so it's hard to define
so so i i tend to not use
the concept of dimension uh in
the sense of another world i like to
think of it
as scales okay so like
a scale scale or another weighing scale
oh scale like a fish
no like uh scales like uh
you know you have atoms that make cells
that makes
bodies that make planet that makes stars
right okay and so imagine that you were
an atom
okay and i you would experience the
world the way you experience it as an
atom so
you would look at other atoms they might
look like stars in the in your sky
and all this stuff and your world would
look a very specific way
and then all of a sudden i grew you up
to a different scale
like your scale today and
you wouldn't recognize the world okay
you would say oh my god
i've gone to another universe i'm what
is going on like yeah what is this right
but you're in the same universe you just
change scale but the shift you wouldn't
even know it you'd just be in a new
reality
right yeah yes exactly so that's
that hey i'm just saying no no but
that's a sideway
a segway we could go into but
basically you know think of it as like
your perspective literally your
coordinates in space-time and how you
see reality and the scale at which you
experience it
defines a lot of how you interpret the
world
right sure but you happen to be made of
smaller scales and smaller scales and
smaller scales and smaller scales so all
these other coordinates in space
all these other perspective all these
other
realities are within you so is it
fractal
yeah exactly maybe explain what
fractions are
because it's fascinating and i don't i
just learned what it was so
right fractals are mathematical
equations that
feed back on themselves so that you take
the answer you feed it back to the
equation and it comes out with another
answer and you
you keep feeding it back and it grows
that's why i was saying earlier it grows
very high level of complexity very
quickly
from a simple set of a of information to
start with right
so so so you're made out of these
divisions of space fractally dividing
this
feedback is it's not just coming at one
scale the feedback is happening at
all the scales that's how it can
self-organize and i can go to the proton
the protons already small right 100
trillion
atoms in the cell a cell is small
an atom is really small a proton is
teeny in the middle of the atom
oh wow and then and then there's
subatomic particles
inside the proton but then you end up at
like a frequency that's called a planck
scale
in which the particle at that level
is so teeny that if i grew it to be a
grain of sand
the proton that it's in would be
the size from alpha centauri to our sun
which is where which is like 40 trillion
kilometers
right that'd be the size of the bubble
wow
okay for the grain of sand to represent
the scale for the proton yeah to
represent the scale yeah so this
particle is so small
that if it's a grain of sand then the
proton is
40 trillion kilometers right
so so so imagine that's inside you
that's oscillating inside you this is
the source of the information flow this
is how
these equations were solved in my
physics
and were able to predict very precisely
extremely precisely the radius of the
proton which is
40 trillion kilometers bigger right so
the fact that the equation is able to
take something
so small and then scale it and predict
the correct size of the protons
remarkable
and then that was verified in labor in
accelerators in switzerland and you know
my prediction was a problem because it's
four percent smaller than the standard
model
so you know that got in some you were
right
i was correct and i am correct because
the co data which is the institution
that sets the standard for all the
constants in physics
adopted that radius you know into your
radius
correct in 2018
so now it's the official radius so
that's so cool
so yeah and but it comes from the
smallest thing
you know imaginable this equation
saying that the proton is actually made
out of trillions of these smaller things
is this because of fractal the natural
fractal that's right
that you know the ratio exactly when you
figure out the pattern then you can
calculate it and it gives the right
answer
so what are we oh my gosh so yeah so
we're this
infinite nature of division
wow right that um that
and you were saying about being
everywhere yeah well when you calculate
the amount of these little particles in
a proton
you can calculate their energy and we
know that energy
you know can equal mass if we multiply
by the speed of light square right
like equals mc square so
when you calculate the mass or the
energy
of the system mass might confuse people
but
the energy of the system you find all
the
information all the energy of the
universe meaning you find
inside a proton the mass of the universe
right in terms of these crazy yes
so imagine you're made out of 100
trillion protons in each cell
and each one of those is a conduit for
the information of
all the other protons in the universe
like they're in
the intricately connected so we should
now talk about quantum entanglement
which is
obviously such a fascinating topic i
mean it's
you know from uh on a really really
micro level when you
you know it's a mother's intuition of
their child right and like oh i think
something's wrong and you call and sure
enough
and right i mean so that's like
obviously an extremely small but that's
a human
way to give a little insight into
entanglement and how so go into that
because it's like fascinating i mean
yeah we're right there
in what i was describing yeah okay great
the fact that sorry to interrupt you no
no no that's good i
you're ahead of me no no no no no no no
there's no way i'm ahead of you on any
of this
i should teach you math you could help
us i would love to
i mean i think i would yeah it's just a
language
actually i'm not you know i i can i do
math but
i i get a lot of help from from good
physicists that helps me and we just
come up with crazy ideas like why does
the dollar have an eye on the top of the
pyramid
and then people just start to think
about things right and somebody else
does the math and i'm like
i have another odd idea here you go
right
because if we're connected to everything
essentially i have the information
like you have the info every single
person has all of the information of the
universe within them
that's right especially based on quantum
entanglement right at a plunk level
we're connected to everything or
something like that i'm saying a lot of
words that i don't completely understand
but
this is vodka that was really good
actually
yeah well you okay i was actually
thinking about this on the beach the
other day
about this statement it was sunset i was
thinking about
the problem is that i was thinking about
equations and then at one point i
stopped myself and i thought you know
there's a sunset it's beautiful
it's amazing maybe i should be here now
and then i was thinking you know that
statement be here now
yes such a weird statement like because
every time i would
think of like being here now i couldn't
feel it
and for me you know for me is like
all of the physics i've written all the
concepts all the philosophy everything
for me it's gotta i gotta be able to
integrate it i gotta be able to
feel it if i can't feel it there's
something wrong with it i gotta
keep digging so i was thinking about
that statement and i was thinking
you know i don't know what here is what
the hell is here
great question you know what is right
now
every now and then yeah we hear now like
in every now moment
in every parallel universe and every
possible outcome that could or couldn't
happen that did or didn't come like
right yes what is here so i try i tried
to modify the statement so it would feel
that i could integrate it and the only
thing i could come up with
and that might sound really weird
because it's the contrary
it was be everywhere at all time yeah
and when i was everywhere
be everywhere and then i could settle
into that oh yeah i can be everywhere
and i could be at all times and i and
and and then i was like oh yeah now i'm
here right
like because i'm everywhere and
so that links to what we were talking
about that
we found in equations
well as i was saying in my equation i
found that it seems like the protons
or the particles are entangled and we're
discovering
we found entanglement a long time ago
with the development of quantum theory
einstein you know einstein called it
spooky action at distance it was a
consequence of the
quantum theory that was written at the
time einstein was wrong
and that was that's he wrote those
papers to disprove
the approach that was being um and it
turned out to be correct meaning
he was right that i was wrong but he was
wrong
that it couldn't happen uh and i
i want to clarify explain yes so
basically
if you take um so
it was discovered from the math that was
being written in quantum theory at the
time
that all of a sudden particles could be
connected at the distance
instantaneously you tickle this particle
over here
and the other one if it's across the
universe if it's entangled would start
laughing
right and very shortly
like in our evolution we were able to
measure that in laboratory
and measure it so that particles were
far away
from each other enough that even at the
speed of light it wouldn't have time to
go and
change the other one before we measure
it so
so we were able to measure that
definitely
particles can be entangled and at this
point we're able to entangle larger
objects
which thought it couldn't be done
because you know i thought to
to be at temperatures that were not
acceptable for quantum theory like
now we can entangle diamonds so that you
you hit this diamond over there with the
laser and the other one is acting like
it's being hit by a laser and so on
and so um so
so that's happening but
it was not described mathematically
clearly meaning the consequence of the
theory was saying yeah particles can do
this
but we're not clear how it's happening
right right
and now recently theories are coming
forward certainly mine
early on and then others from very good
physicists the top guys
uh showing that actually there's micro
wormholes that are connecting these
things and mar
and wormholes are a consequence of
einstein field equation that's why i was
saying he was right
meaning he was wrong that it couldn't be
done
but he was right that it wasn't
from specific the specific equations
that were given at the time
that this was happening that there was
something more classical which is
a wormhole and so there's these little
tunnels
that connects particles this is called
er equals
epr and technical jargon in math
yeah i don't understand and and
basically showing that
and then imagine a particle that that
falls into a black hole
that's entangled with another one right
right and then the other one falls into
another black hole sure
now these black holes are entangled now
the black holes are entangled yes
and we know particles are falling into
black holes
right right so now black holes are
entangled
entangled and the particles are
entangled and
all of a sudden it's like very quickly
you come to conclude wow
the whole thing is entangled right
although we
don't see it clearly because when we
look at the particle
when we tickle it over here we might not
be aware there's another particle on the
other side of the universe that's
laughing when we tickle it because we
don't have a measurement on that right
we're not over there looking at it
that's right we're not measuring
so we only see the integral and for
particles that we entangle ourself and
that we can measure both sides
right what does this mean for us so that
means that we live in a neural network
literally that spans from the infinitely
small to the infinitely big
and just recently papers were published
showing that uh mathematically when you
look at
super clusters filaments there's these
huge filaments of plasma that connects
super cluster in this amazing
you know structures are those those
pretty pictures of yeah yeah the colors
and the
exactly yeah they look just like neural
network
in your brain that's literally what i
was just about to say
like i imagine because i'm not again i i
mean
i have a ged like i didn't even go to
college
but like i get these ideas of things and
i'm like
i i like the brain the way that it fires
like the whole like webbing
i'm like that's the universe that's how
we're connected
right so you're saying that's is that
what you're saying that's correct
yeah well we're starting to see evidence
of it we live
and then there's physics that's being
written not only by me but others
that are showing yeah you know if you
write physics in such a way to describe
reality as a neural network
thing starts to add up properly and
so so so think of everything being
entangled
and since you're made out of that stuff
yeah you're entangled with the whole
thing
and your brain might be you see your
consciousness
might not be some chemical change in
your brain
your chemical change in your brain is
just a result of the information
going through the neural network and
so your consciousness is not inside your
body but your consciousness is the
relationship
of you with the this field
you know you can think of a web of
information at all the scales that
connects all the scales
and this is how i wrote these equations
i'm finishing this paper
that i've been working on for like you
know three years i publish
i mean i've been going at it for 30
years but this is like
and it's coming all circle like full
circle this
is a crazy part is that from studying
ancient civilization
and these symbols and all this stuff
from the old times when i was in the van
you know living by myself you know
agnostic
you know like crazy guy um
you know studying 20 hours somebody's
got to be crazy
somebody's gonna go at it crazy people
change the world well
yeah typically you figure it out
actually they're not figuring out the
world they're figuring out the universe
well
the multiverse or the whatever yeah the
entire
the fractal fractal existence of
us exactly and what's crazy
is that these thoughts i was having them
are coming full circle but now with the
equations
and so that's just interesting right
that you've had the thought
without the information without
the proof right or the science or the
math the language
but yet you knew it right because you're
everything
right you already know i knew that i
just don't know how to get to it exactly
you didn't need to go to college i mean
i'm in the high school dropout
right all right cheers
you know i got in the ski industry i got
in the climbing industry
you know you're a surfer i'm a surfer
you know like you you got into sport
industry
driving cars whatever but i you know
the the fact is and i teach this for all
this time and people recognize it
because they can
feel it yeah and because they can feel
it just know it they know it
and if it's true they know it and any
great
discovery that was made in history was
because somebody had a gut feeling
you know somebody not the equation
first right but the gut feeling
maybe this is how it works and then
the equation and then the equation
supports it or not
right maybe you're a little wrong but
maybe it directs you
so it's the relationship between the
outside world and your internal
dialogue you know that
internal dialogue you have yeah right oh
yeah
who is it with well right i mean that's
the thing like i mean in the book on
tethered soul it was like
if you're having thoughts how do you
know you're having thoughts
right what's looking at you to know
you're having thoughts
exactly it's like something is beyond or
above
or outside right of us
otherwise like the ocean's not thinking
like i'm a wave here i go
right it's just the ocean right right so
how do i know
that i have a wave or a thought exactly
and so basically
you are you are the universe talking to
yourself
you're having the dialogue with all of
creation
all of creation is listening yep to what
you're saying
so all of a sudden wow you have a
responsibility
right it's like i had an experience
i lived in big island for a while on
uh no i'm sorry on the big island in the
kalakuka
kalakakua and in kalakakua bay the
dolphins come
and they love to swim with doll with
humans right
and so we used to go swimming with them
this is a long time ago in the early
2000s
and um and for the longest time
the local community would tell me oh
yeah you know dolphins can
hear everything you think they you know
their psychic and so on
and i was like yeah okay you know local
folklore you know i had fun with them
but i
just i didn't think they could and then
at one point
i was after like a few months of
swimming with them almost every day
i was thinking wow you know i was i got
i befriended this young dolphin
and we used to go you know swim
twirling and jumping and all this stuff
and
every morning every mermaid in existence
person that feels like they're a mermaid
i have one of those friends
is very jealous of this story right now
yeah it was amazing but anybody can do
that i guess right and that's what
you're going to start to
get to right well basically at one point
i was wondering because when
she was playing with all the other
dolphins they would bump against each
other and all this and you know i can
free dive to like
110 feet and so on like so
at 60 feet i can hang for a while so i
would go down with her
and then twirl back up and all this but
but she would
never ever bump against me or touch me
or
anything and if i tried to touch her she
would move her body exactly
the same distance and i didn't know
and so i was thinking as i was swimming
with her at one point
why why don't they touch us and
and so on maybe they don't they think
you know kind of humans are kind of
gross
you know they're kind of weird you know
and then
then i thought maybe i didn't give her
permission to touch me so i thought in
my head
i gave you permission to touch me and
she just rubbed
all over me like in that instant and
you know and then i realized oh my god
they can't hear us
and i thought oh my god what have i been
thinking all this time
like what other thoughts have i been
having and what were those things doing
exactly and and so the the reason i was
telling you this story is that when you
realize
oh maybe i'm in the new network of the
universe
and and i'm actually interacting with it
and actually
these inner thoughts and this inner
dialogue i'm having is actually a
dialogue with the whole
then you realize okay you know i have a
responsibility
about what i'm telling the universe
right what am i doing
you know and it's not like hey i get
angry
i get pissed off i start swearing i do
all kinds of stuff like we
called being human right yeah yeah
exactly we fail
all the time but how much
of that is happening and how much of the
other is happening like i'm
how constructive i am you know like i
started to
edit when i realized that i start to
edit my
thoughts my internal dialogue not just
let it run you know
because we have such a negative bias on
ourselves
why is that why what is the if we're
that in if we are the universe and we
are
we have this power
why is it that as a species we are so
hard on ourself and have such negative
thoughts and are so limiting
well i think that because we don't know
how beautiful we are our incredible
you know our existence is that we even
are here thinking about it you know we
don't
like we lose if we think we're separate
and we're the result of some random
event and it's
just kind of like a luck that we got
here and we're going to disappear
the universe won't care you know then
you know it's you
you can have a negative bias because you
don't
actually know what you are who you are
but when you discover this doesn't mean
your negative bias just goes away right
like when i see myself in the mirror as
i walk to the bathroom in the morning so
you know i get many thoughts of like oh
my god look awful right
but i tried to edit them as they come up
but
basically you know
realizing and appreciating
the amazing miracle we are you know
we have to know we are to be able to do
that
if we don't know then this the
our society is certainly not gonna help
us
feel good about ourselves right our
society
is very much set up to be critical
and you know if you're not exactly like
this and if you're not exactly like that
you know you're you're it's not
acceptable and so on like
you see this is the other thing is that
i think that an evolutionary step
for humanity is to realize we're all
part of the same source
right that would be the first step right
we're all part of the same source we're
all part of the same field the same
neural network
and and then from there uh
you know this idea of separation
becomes less and less and mutual support
becomes more and more important because
you realize wow
you know in order to help me
i got to be able to help the whole
network i gotta you know i gotta be
a productive positive impact on the
network
right so then it becomes easier
to self you know um
uh control meaning that
you know we have laws that tells us
what's right and what's wrong
right you can do this but you cannot do
this and
i imagine that eventually
an advanced society doesn't require this
because internally you know
what's right and what's wrong right
i would like to think the same thing i
would like to think that as you ascend
as your consciousness or
your self-awareness opens up that
there's no need for
even government on some level because
you are your own governing body
and you don't operate under lower
frequency
under a lower frequency existence of
things that would
create problems right they might be
social organization but they would be
built
more like a neural network it would be a
distributed note
you know decentralized and so on so that
you know ever
it would be different imagine if
everybody has gravitational drives which
we will have
if we make it say with that what does
that mean
gravitational drives yeah that we are
able to
have a spaceship that doesn't use fuel
oh right like cars drives rides right
right so you
just distort space time in that region
so that you can get
lift right so all of a sudden you can go
to the moon for the weekend you can go
to jupiter
whatever like all of a sudden and the
concept of government
governance changes right it would be
totally different
totally like so young jupiter i mean
there might be a different more
localized body of
you know our organization and so on so
it might look much less like a
centralized body like we have today
but much more you know network
kind of structure so are we essentially
an aspect of the universe organizing
itself
until we and then as soon as we do
it rolls into another it's like sort of
like the universe problem solving itself
into expansion
on some level exactly and like we just
go
helping like we as a consciousness like
or as a self-aware network
as a as a neuro network of information
now it just goes sort of to the next
problem or the next
species the next existence because i've
heard
there was somebody that was you know i
was like what's the point of being here
and they're like well you know you
expand and to the point you you uh
we basically raise our frequency our
consciousness enough
that we sort of
transcend ascend and then we go do that
for the next sort of
existence yeah or another existence as
if you know from a
more esoteric sort of like like the
palladians and the octurians and the
whatever and they're
they're like helping us from a planet
from another from other star
systems right so i'm kind of piecing
together a lot of my thoughts but right
but it more breaks down to like
organization
of information like are we waiting to
organize our information so that we can
then go
right the universe expands on that level
and then you go to the next level of
yeah you can see it in uh biological
evolution
right on our planet i used to hang out
with
a great evolutionary biologist
elizabeth satura saturus that uh
that was um she she used to tell me this
it
it really hit me hard when she told me
this is that you know
bacterial system like monocellular
bacterial system
early on in our evolution almost went
extinct
because they were competing and
at the time the pollution they were
producing was
oxygen and it was killing them right
they were dying
and they almost went extinct until they
started to collaborate
and then they made you know
multicellular system that could breed
the oxygen
right and and eventually produce our
evolution
right so so it's like we go through
yeah we're doing the same thing exactly
history from a theo
like theological standpoint from the
mythological stories like stories are
cyclical
right resistance is cyclical from an
expansion standpoint exactly
it's simple and then it gets complex
more and more complex yeah
it's like the neural network goes jump
quantas
in organization but at it at each
level it has to unify yeah
you know it has to connect and then as
soon as it does that then it can go to
the next level imagine
if humanity today all of a sudden
became unified meaning that races was
not a problem anymore
that borders were not a problem anymore
that we just realized oh we're all on
the same planet
and we have to collaborate to
get to the next level we have everything
we need
to really transform our civilization
into
space colonies and all this but that has
to happen it has
the it's like um in the laboratory
if you take a surface like a balloon and
you put energy onto it like you
oscillate it
it will go into chaotic modes and
more energy you put in more chaotic it
becomes
and when it gets to the point where it's
like at the maximum of
energy gets so chaotic the surface
tension of the balloon might break and
the whole thing explodes and then you're
done but
but if the surface tension of the of the
balloon is strong enough
and you put a little more energy all of
a sudden it organizes
into a higher frequency and it becomes
coherent again right it it rings at a
higher frequency so
that means it can have more information
and it
has a coherent behavior that's not so
destructive
that's not so chaotic it goes into order
and so we're right at that point in our
evolution
i think that we have this opportunity to
go to the next
level do you think we will or are we
going to screw it up
i i think we're running against the
clock
and that um we have a great
opportunity to do it and it's going to
require
everybody to get involved
you know the fact that you're doing this
show that you know
it's gonna it's gonna take everybody
to get involved to be able to like
bring this level of awareness to the
planet right
and to bring the science that goes with
it
you know because i can write the physics
and
you know the physics i'm about to
publish are
remarkable i needed to
be published at the highest level i
needed
to be acknowledged by other you know and
all this
that requires that there's the
willingness that there is you know
to to think at that level to you know
the math speaks for itself and actually
college students
with a little help will be able to
follow the math
so you know what about uh ged you know
level students
you will i should i'll show you you have
a resonance uh
there's a there's a school there's a
right what's it called
it's called a resident science
foundation right yeah and so
and we have a course i should enroll
yeah it's great we have a hundred
thousand people taking a course right
now
approximately um i think we're just
under a hundred thousand and
we're about to add so this six module
takes a few months to go through or a
few weeks depending how dedicated you
are
but uh but uh we're about to add module
seven and module eight which will
explain the new paper so
uh you know you'll be able you'll see
actually the concepts are very palatable
uh
you know if if you're not interested in
understanding the math the concepts
are very palatable like i can teach
this to a teenager and they will follow
they will understand um it's not
it basically describes scales resonating
at different frequency
and coupling you know the relationship
of these
oscillating frequency from infinitely
small to infinitely big and
and then you just do the math and you
end up oh wow there's the proton oh
there's the electron oh wow
there's you know the redbird constant oh
here's the gravitational constant
oh wow look this is the universe oh this
is the temperature of the universe
because of the nature of fractals
whether it's like
sacred geometry or you know um
trying to think of all of the different
things that i've seen that are
mathematical but
that the ratios like the golden ratio
right like all of those things
they they're universal right and you
find them in nature everywhere right so
you know there's
order there's structure it's just we
hadn't put all the pieces together right
you don't i didn't do anything you have
all the pieces well i didn't do anything
fantastic
they give me like the you know the
pieces were all there they just hadn't
been put in this
yeah but it kind of leads me to a
thought that i've had so many times
which has to do and you mentioned it
earlier but it has to do with the
you know this like construct of school
and the books and the learning and
getting inside the box and
you know thank goodness that you
were you felt this drive
to learn your own way because it's
through asking those kinds of questions
and learning in a new way
if we it's like the definition of
insanity if you want the same result
just keep doing what you're doing like
if you want to keep
existing in the same universe just keep
reading the same books but
right you need to ask new questions and
write new books exactly
and and in order to write new i ask new
questions
you have to be able to be on your own
enough right meaning you can't just be
getting
fed information from the outside it's
got to come from
inside okay explain your inside would
you where do you get it from
when you say you go inside yeah what are
the moments that you
have explain when you have a vision an
epiphany a moment
of thought like where does it arrive and
how does it arrive
well my first epiphany i think
in terms of physics was um
probably when i was around 11 years old
and i luckily um
my family came in contact with a indian
guru at the time
that was teaching um meditation
and i learned to meditate and at the
time was a very
you know unusual thing to do never mind
at the age of 11.
but when i started meditating
um you know at first i was like wow you
know this is seriously boring you know
you're 11.
right am i doing this right yeah what am
i doing you know i'm just thinking about
lunch exactly you know so
i you know but then eventually when i
quiet things down a little um i got this
i i was thinking like what is this
meditation thing what am i doing and
then i thought well i'm turning my
senses
inwards right and then kind of listening
to what's going on in there
and so my first epiphany
was oh there's a world inside
and there's a world outside and in
between
is a boundary and there's information
going in the boundary
and this information going out the
boundary right when i do things i'm
putting information into the outside
right
and i'm capting information from the
outside through my senses so
i was thinking oh so that was my first
thought
in this evolution of physics is
oh so the the exchange of information
could be the source of the energy of
creation
right yeah it was and there yeah that's
all i needed
really that's all i need the rest has
been just
the next layer is how did you
trust that or like how did it feel
why did that feel different well
i was an unusual kid and i didn't fit in
this the educational system very well
although my father was you know revered
as one of the
greatest child psychologists he was oh
wow you know
it was the protege of piaget psja
institute in
switzerland is the i mean the it's like
the father of child psychology
and so on um i just didn't fit in the
educational system i was just
my father's worst nightmare and uh
this i was like it's only natural that
he would get
a doozy or someone who didn't want to be
in that right like
oh my god life life shows life gives us
interesting lessons i was a good
engineer yeah
yeah exactly so he he learned to deal
with me
but uh basically and i learned to deal
with him but
um and we love each other so for me
it was like okay i wasn't getting
from the world around me a very coherent
picture of reality
yeah and i had these deep questions like
what is reality how did i get here you
know the question you're asking
right and and and and that everybody
should ask
you know we can attempt to go on the you
know
on on on the mouse wheel you know that's
turning and in the world we
we forget to ask deeper questions so for
me it was like
because i was alone like i i i didn't
get along with the educational system i
didn't really have many friends and all
this
i reflected on the nature of reality
deeply
and a lot of quiet time yeah
i had a lot of quiet inner and outer
worlds exactly and then
skiing and climbing you know nature yeah
nature i could see the beauty everywhere
i could see the relationship between
things and nature
that supported each other right like you
get a b you get a flower
right like and i was wondering why in
the universe put the flower on one
planet and to be on another
you know that that would have not worked
right so how they didn't know to put
them on the same planet right
and things like that and so i was like
really and and and but i was in the ski
industry i was successful i mean it was
a long journey
you know how that is when you want to
get to the elite of a sport
yeah and um i was well known i was one
of the top guys in
you know um instructor in canada now
you're gonna have to go teach me
and well i need the help that would be
fun i'd like to go
dance dance with gravity i'll drive
there and you
you teach me how to skate okay oh i'm a
terrible
uh driver no i'm a terrible teacher
no um how do you say backseat driver
oh got it you're gonna scare the crap
out of me
oh oh god i thought you were gonna tell
me how to do it and i was like bring it
on that's fine no
no no no i trust you on that
i'm sure you got that down uh but um
but yeah so i had this accident and
um i had been for years
doing physics at night on the side but
and
you know in the ski industry i wasn't
going to start talking physics to all my
friends and stuff so i didn't say
anything to anybody especially at the
time i was doing a lot of
ancient civilization stuff as well and
symbolism and all this so i didn't say
anything i haven't
yeah but then i had the ex the accident
year a few years you know into after
i started to talk and because i i
retired from the
ski industry not because i was injured
but because
it for me was a sign that i needed to do
something else
and uh uh i
what's funny about it is that when i
started to talk about this then
the rumor went around the ski industry
is like yeah
nassim got hit by a snowmobile and now
he's doing physics
you know that's not the whole story
right
but he's like yeah we're not sure if
he's got all his head
no he's not yeah he's not all up here
he's not all there
is changing the world so it
seems to me though like you like this
would be this is this is the last
question
so if it sounds like you've answered
your ultimate question that you had at
11.
yeah so what is your next
question well the the
beauty is that you can have a very high
thought
right like a very general high thought
about something that might be very true
but as you explore that thought and
actually
work out the details of it you learn
so much more that you know it just
continues to expand the question circle
exactly and you learn more and more and
it's like you're going down the fractal
path and you and and there's another one
yes and you know it's like
it's like all of a sudden you know you
find this new equation for instance
right and you go wow
what's this telling me right and you
you can see that it's related to the
general thought you had
but now it's now you're integrating the
mechanics on how
it's actually happening right and you
can calculate the frequency
you can calculate the energy you can
calculate the force
and and now it's like you feel it inside
your body
happening and so to me i've just gained
deeper and deeper deeper understanding
of of me you know
as a result that
just blows my doors
again yesterday right right like it's
not
stop i keep finding deeper stuff that
just blows my mind
all related to this general thought but
but knowing the mechanics is so
fundamental it's so it has a deep impact
on your
awareness your consciousness your it
transforms you
at the really deep level and
um and and
and and as a result it props up the next
question
it's like this it's like the science and
the equations
organize you that's how it feels in my
head like it
organizes it's uh it's proof and it's
like
um it's uh tangible it's
you know like it organizes you and then
you go to the next theory or idea
right and then you organize at that
level right that's how it kind of feels
in my
in my body like yeah just like that
network growing yes yeah yeah exactly it
organizes at each level
and then you know at each level
there's technological consequences and
benefits
yeah exactly that are not just
philosophical
or right you know nice mathematics that
kind of works out
it has implication and like energy
production
control of forces and so on that
really can trans transform the world
and transform your capacity to be
harmonious with nature harmonious with
the world
you know to work with the world you know
to put your energy production little
turbine
in the natural flow of creation
right so that so that you create
positive impact on your environment
and and then your society becomes not
only sustainable
it thrives because the universe
truly thrives you know so then
ultimately knowing
what you know and what you've proven now
what is that what is the what is the
next fundament what is the fundamental
lesson that comes from that that
directly applies to how you live your
life
well certainly like i was saying earlier
you start editing your thoughts your
story
you know like how what am i producing
how am i producing
you know like what am i feeding the
universe when am i teaching the universe
right am i limiting my
my thoughts am i limiting myself am i
do i have a negative bias that you know
because if i'm feeding that to the
feedback well you know then it's
probably gonna have some negative effect
in my surroundings
and so on and and i as i want to say
clearly like we all fail you know it's
not like i'm i'm
able to maintain you know this higher
thought
thank you for saying that i mean i think
that's important to uh to
for someone that's proven this out you
still are
human essentially absolutely and you
know if you ask my staff they'll tell
you
um you know because i get upset or you
know i get cut off on the highway and
you know you know what sometimes the
universe collapses certain things
right like things collapse and they just
you know just collide
and it's just it's part of the
undoing redoing kind of thing and so you
have to be
you have to be patient with yourself you
have to be you have to
know that that's part of the evolution
yeah right it's not
a separate part it's part like to learn
to walk you fell
right you fell and then you figured out
how to walk and then you fell again and
so you know this uh
so so you i mean at the deepest level
you d you start to realize the miracle
of life
that's another implication you start to
have
deep level of appreciation you know for
every
for every moment that you're alive and
hopefully you're able to like take a
moment every day
to express that to the universe you know
to express your love to the universe
and to receive from the universe because
you know a lot of us are good at
expressing
the not so good at receiving it right
so that that's another thing you know
it's like so it has
implication in how you you live your
life every day
but as well uh it has implication in
technology
that will change the way we do things i
can't wait
and so you know all of a sudden if we
have access to almost
like the density of the vacuum at the
planck scale
is 10 to the 93 grams per centimeter
cube so
just so the listeners understand what
that means
uh the the mass of the universe is 10 to
the 55
grams so that that's the energy of all
the mass
all the matter in the universe 10 to the
55 grams
you know for evolving the energy of the
universe of the universe
so in the centimeter cube of plunk
oscillators of space those little
particles
there's 10 to the 93 what
grams so there's 39 38 orders of
magnitude
more energy than all the energy in the
universe
this is the tubes right this is the
connection right it's both
right exactly that is the information
moving through
that's the energy of the universe
through this field
and so if we extract
like you know we just gotta take one of
those tubes
and plug it into our machine and if we
just tap it's like plugging into the
universal
net right all of a sudden if we
extracted one billionth of a percent
of the energy in a centimeter cube of
space we would have enough energy to run
the whole planet
yeah for thousands of years okay so
so so then all of a sudden energy
becomes
infinite you have as much energy as you
want
so then the value of things is no longer
how rare it is like because now you can
go
mine gold on any planet you want you can
you know you can do anything you want
so all of a sudden it's what you're
doing with it
it's creativity that's important that's
the true value
right and so basically
it will change things very fundamentally
from one simple discovery
is that energy is everywhere and we can
have access to it
you know and then it implies as well if
you apply that to einstein fill equation
that you can
warp space time that means you can have
warp drives
that means you can overcome gravity that
means you can
okay is this happening in our lifetime
oh yes
this is on its way warp drives have been
worked on at nasa currently
there is many laboratories around the
world working on this gravity control
i believe is going to happen in our
lifetime so
so we're going to mars yeah we're going
to jupiter we'll make it i'd like to
visit
ryan's belt is that possible yes
that might be possible that is a longer
trip
so that'll take a wormhole but it may be
in our lifetime that we're able to open
a wormhole i mean it has an
implication as well on life extension
you know and so wait a second so the ev
the universe is expanding and it's
actually
expanding because it's growing it's it's
growing and it's and it's
it's growing more and more rapidly yeah
is this exactly because again it's all
the same like paralleling right is this
exactly how our technology will go to
like all of a sudden we'll be like
oh look i can fly oh look i'm on orion's
belt all of a sudden like
exactly right yes exactly it's like
before you know you could get
a little far away from the cave you know
to go hunting and come back to the cave
that was pretty well how far you could
go
and then we got better at going farther
right we got horses and stuff and and
then we got
cars we got a little farter and then we
got planes and now we got a little
farther
and then all of a sudden we can go in
our solar system
right and then gravity control
so basically our modern evolution
of technology is all because we learn to
control electromagnetic fields
right with maxwell's equation fair basic
work and all this we learn how to make
electricity control
charge control electromagnetic field so
we can communicate to our
phones and all this stuff the next step
is we're gonna learn to control gravity
right and then all of a sudden we're
gonna remember
how to control gravity we're gonna
remember very good
very good very good that's good um yeah
exactly there's evidence that that was
done before
okay well where's first where where are
you gonna go so
well you know i think the first or your
ultimate destination where's your
vacation
in my case yeah i get a thousand year
vacation
yes where's your thousand year vacation
where are you taking oh another universe
i'm going
straight up i'm going wherever you're
going because i feel like you've got
your finger on the pulse
thank you um i yes i i mean i think
initially just like planes at first were
doing like
inside the continent flying you know
short distances
and then intercontinental flight and
stuff
i think initially we're gonna be able to
birth our civilization into our solar
system
you know meaning we'll be able to easily
go to planetary systems
mars you know the the moons of jupiter
and so on
wow and that already will be a huge step
in our events yeah yeah because i mean
you ask any astronaut
that has been in space and look back at
the earth and all of them
report the same feeling it's like oh wow
it's so easy to feel like everybody's
one yeah the way it's not flat yeah and
it's not flat
correct you know that uh
you know and so it will be a change in
consciousness for people to even just
look back at the earth and
feel oh yeah of course we're just one
race right
but do you think that we'll actually be
thinking back or will we just be in a
new existence without
like the um
not perspective that's not the right
word but it will be
just a fluid evolution
that will be
a new norm yeah you know of course yeah
or will we be looking back at ourselves
going damn i'm smart look at that
holy crap we're on jupiter's moon right
now can you believe when we just lived
on earth
dude that sucked of course for the
for our generation we'll probably have
some of these thoughts
wow look at where we were look if i'm on
jupiter's moon
in my lifetime i'm definitely going to
be saying that right
but i the generation future won't even
have a concept of being stuck on the
surface of a planet
totally you know it would be like wow
what must have been
really bad just like when we think
of people in the past that couldn't even
go
a few miles right or change continents
right right so so
i think it's that change and this is
just the result of one thing
is to actually understand some
fundamental physics
about the structure of space it's all
it's just one thing it's just one
discovery
right and and and just like maxwell's
equation
just like you know einstein relativity
you know it changed things quantum
theory
you know marx quantum theory like
a lot of the devices we use today is
because these equations were written
well it's just a new equation yeah that
define gravity
more fundamentally and it will change
everything
thank you for thinking different thank
you for thinking
outside of the book thank you i
appreciate it
it's been a long journey and i'm really
grateful to have had it
and uh and i'm grateful as well for the
people
that did the work before me because like
i said i just put the pieces together
that were already there
and and i'm grateful as well for the
people that resisted it
because they forced me to be very
rigorous and
to you know really push forward and
continue so it's part of the journey you
know
how do you polish the the crystal you
know it's a great perspective
thank you thank you thanks everybody for
listening to the pretty intense podcast
today i hope you enjoyed it
if you like what you heard today and you
want to hear more please click on the
subscribe button